auf und bediene präsentiert von der
leyen verlängert oder weniger lang weg
sind
[Musik]
vom berner oberland in den spanischen
süden miriam thomann und ostsee erfüllen
sich den traum vom leben auf einer
pferde finca
auf einer großen farm im westen kanadas
will familie ruckstuhl endlich ihr glück
finden
mit vier tigern war trainer müller das
abenteuer er wandert zu seiner freundin
alexandra tate nach deutschland aus sie
bauen einen tierpark
[Musik]
endlich endlich ist es perfekt denn
endlich ist auch miri an tormann in
ihrer neuen heimat im süden spaniens
angekommen
als erstes zeigt ihr usd nachwuchs auf
der pferde finca
[Applaus]
so hat sich
der könig als schluss ja
doch li na hatte sowie die nachtlinie
buch
traumhaft
heftig das ist richtiger paradies
in der letzten folge von auf und davon
arbeitete miriam tormann noch in der
schweiz
freundes partie ist bereits in spanien
und findet ihn geschäftspartner robert
halter seinen meister
das wissen stift die lehrlinge gemeinsam
legten sie die geschäftsbereiche fest
geschäft betrieb
geschäft der zucht in deutschland
bezogen remo müllers tiger ihr neues
gegen
[Musik]
zwei jahre pendelte tiertrainer remo
zwischen der schweiz und deutschland
nun ist er endlich mit freundin
alexandra tee zusammen
familie ruckstuhl ist zum zweiten mal
nach kanada ausgewandert wegen der
krankheit ihrer tochter hatte ihr erster
versuch ein jähes ende gefunden die
familie kehrte in das häuschen zurück
dass sie bereits vor zwei jahren bewohnt
hatte
[Musik]
mit der ankunft von miriam ist das team
auf los angeles komplett
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eine von miriams aufgaben ist das kochen
für rheydt gäste team kollegin barbara
hat jahrelange erfahrung darin
[Musik]
ja dass du scharf treffen ob das was sie
ja ernährungs gefühl mehr machen dass
kurzarbeit gutes team das auf jeder
landwirt
wenn irgendwas ist okay es ist ja du
kriegst kein rot nicht so die leute
haben so nett sind schmeckt alles
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
im tierpark in bel faulenzen remo
müllers raubkatzen im warmen strom
[Musik]
draußen ist es kalt und der ganze park
eine baustelle
siebeneinhalb hektar groß ist das
gelände die ziegen hat remo vom alten
besitzer übernommen noch leben sie in
einem matschigen provisorium
der 35 jährige hat ein ehrgeiziges ziel
alle tiere sondern ein neues zuhause
bekommen aber in gut einem monat ist
bereits eröffnet ja mein mann und ich
hätte gar nicht bis zur eröffnung aber
dicke da
sind wirklich gut drauf also besser was
ich denke da dann machen wir einfach mit
dem was man hat also verlangen eventuell
sonderrabatt trainiert tritt irgendwo
bis aber
wenigstens grob den staaten immer noch
zum
schaffen
das ist richtig
das gut huskies
jona
und seiner seite hat remo freundin
alexandra auch ihre huskys bekommen ein
neues zuhause
die hunde hat alexandra pitz aus
verschiedenen tierheimen gut sie ist
tiertrainerin und die re philosophie ist
einfach zitieren eine zweite chance
geben
die hbl hat sich in der sonne liegen
heute morgen ponys
von wo die unbedingtheit wellen
abgefragt ob man nicht noch ponys
brauchen und
der heimat von der gurt ponys braucht
man sowieso und sie hätten eigentlich
gewünscht platz gefunden waren keine
zeit mehr gab und
hummer gefunden
dann übernahm als
erster überhaupt
für die tiger so die heimat schmalz auf
große aufkommt wenn es im zuchtprogramm
nicht gestanden sind und schwierig sie
war für alle ihren platz finden und dann
haben wir deutschen eigentlich sollte
die reise durch hamit und verdienen
eigentlich sind wir dass großes tier
hast du lebst du zwei
ein großes tierheim dass sich bald der
öffentlichkeit präsentieren und damit
geld verdienen muss
[Musik]
hält sie durchgemacht
haben sie mal lernen
[Musik]
in kanada ist fast schon alltag
eingekehrt die kinder fühlen sich in
ihrem neuen heim
vater markus ist bereits schon wieder
unterwegs
[Musik]
und
es hat geklappt doch mit dem dietrich
sind so einer rechten gruppe helfer und
war
bis jetzt einmal gut verzinst
[Musik]
markus ruckstuhl ist ausgewandert weil
er hier seinen traum leben kann arbeiten
auf einer farm mit riesigen
landmaschinen immer in der natur draußen
doch heute muss er schreien an eine
arbeit mit der er schon in der schweiz
sein geld verdient hatte
[Musik]
dank der zimmermannsarbeiten kann markus
auch während der zeit wenn die natur auf
den feldern arbeitet geld verdienen 23
dollar auf die stunde bekommt er
ausbezahlt aber nur wenn es arbeit hat
heute soll er eine terrasse für das haus
der saison arbeiter bauen
[Musik]
der 30 jährige ist gelernter landwirt
und zimmermann dank der kombination
dieser beiden berufe kam markus familie
einfacher zu einem visum
henry der sohn eines arbeitskollegen
hilft beim bau
gib mir mal bitte
das ist nicht wirklich ein hammer war
das ist fürchterlich oder ist das
einzige was ich gefunden habe sonst
musst du einen stein gehen
lernen
lokalität dass er qualität denn der
klassische witz unterschiedlich sind
weniger zufrieden
solange es keine wohnen und grad statt
jedes kürzen so heißt es schon genau
bestimmt
ihr habt eure stimmen wie zusätzliche
erzieher sind ja alles kontrolliert
[Musik]
auf der pferde finca los angeles zeigt
ein mitarbeiter miriam was auf den
frühstückstisch kommt
feriengäste angestellte und die finger
chefs auf los angeles essen alle
zusammen
beim frühstück bekommen die reitschüler
ihr pferd für den ausritt zugeteilt die
einteilung der pferde und ehrgeiz ist
natürlich chefsache
es geht darum was
ja ja
kaum noch ins merkel ich wurde stand
vieles ist neu für miriam vieles wird
sie lernen müssen doch die größte
herausforderung wird sein ihren platz im
team zu finden
ich würde sogar bis
wenn wir mehr zurückgegangen sind und
der brite braucht hilfe
[Musik]
remus größter stolz ist das tigergehege
das hat er selber konstruiert er zeigt
es miriam einer ehemaligen
arbeitskollegin aus der schweiz die zu
besuch ist um ihm zu helfen
das narrative mondlandschaft am samstag
machte doch noch die letzte sache jetzt
wo der schnee weg ist nachher da wird
auch zeit und dann hoffen wir dass es
relativ schnell eine mall wird aber es
ist aller allerbeste ist das da oben
also denkens blick
haben
2300 quadratmeter groß ist dass tiger
gelände mit welchen und swimmingpool nur
betreten dürfen die raubkatzen ihr reich
noch nicht
jetzt in krina schritte immer bitter
wenn man es jetzt für den salon
einspringt buschinger und fürchtet sich
nachher und veganen stahl retour
dann können wir das vertrauen in mein
berufliches natürlichen ein rechter
blickt geburtsland
wir selber noch nicht ob ich
nochmal größer
der schweizer und park oder nur einfach
so das kleid kaufen mit einer
bewilligung
unmöglich also hätte meine omi entlang
rechte und in der schweiz hat mir für
das geld nicht im malersaal familie
[Musik]
für alle auswanderer sind die ersten
tage in der neuen heimat stets speziell
für remo ist dieser tag zusätzlich etwas
besonderes
auf ihn wartet eine überraschung
[Musik]
das geburtstagsgeschenk
[Gelächter]
das ist ein spiel
selbst gesagt
du musst
du darfst jetzt nicht mit dem ziel dass
du halt hochkommt wissen dass oberst und
auch dass ein ball labyrinth
und wir haben ja eigentlich überlegt
dass man ja sowas auf einem spielplatz
gut gebrauchen können ich glaube das
ding auch heute kommt ein
geschicklichkeitsspiel für ihren
liebsten
daher wird sie zum medium liege schlange
[Musik]
in der cafeteria des tierparks
überraschen freunde und helfer das
geburtstagskind mit weiteren geschenken
[Gelächter]
das ist cool die kinder das leben wollen
ich bekomme alles mit sieger
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
in kanada hat markus inzwischen den
fehler an der konstruktion entdeckt der
sich zum glück einfach korrigieren lässt
gut eine autostunde entfernt liegt das
spital von calgary
josephine hat ihren ersten arzttermin
letztmals war alexandra mit ihr vor zwei
jahren hier
in diesem spital hatten die ärzte eine
lebensbedrohende stoffwechselkrankheit
bei josephine entdeckt zur behandlung
der krankheit eine
stammzellentransplantation
kehrte die familie in die schweiz zurück
die therapie war soweit erfolgreich
gesund jedoch ist die kleine nicht
ärztlicher untersuchungen finden nun
zurück in kanada im spital von calgary
statt
hallo schön dich wiederzusehen
du schaust gesund und gut aus
so nun bin ich gespannt wie alles
gelaufen ist
die dancing hat es probleme gegeben
das herz ist gut die lungen sind gut die
lehrer die mir alles ist gut da war
flüssigkeit in ihrem gehirn wir haben
die schweizer ärzte gesagt dass es
behandelt werden muss sie haben gesagt
dass es auf dem jüngsten emily besser
ausschaut
wenn du dich gerade so wohl fühlt dann
wollen wir dich doch gleich untersuchen
ja ja ja
wie eine prinzessin krone
wie sich die organe und gelenke von
josephine entwickeln werden ist
schwierig zu sagen
doch doktor kahn ist im moment zufrieden
zum glück gibt es keine herzprobleme das
ist echt ein großer vorteil
mit dem spitalbesuch ist der alltag in
kanada definitiv eingekehrt
hani
kompanie
egal ob sie selber geduldig
blättern sie es noch knapp
ja
mk
[Musik]
in spanien wird mir ja nichts geschenkt
sie muss sich durchsetzen und das gegen
einen mann wie robert der sich nichts
sagen ist
natürlich dass ich bin
wenn ich
das
ist es
und sein angestellter bessern auf der
pferde finger zäune aus
ich habe familie in stuttgart
[Musik]
die elektrische zäune sind in desolatem
zustand wenn sie nicht unter strom sind
können die junghengste ungehindert die
weide wechseln im nu wären sie bei den
jungen stuten
es hat keinen strom
das
ist doch nicht normal
die angestellten haben die elektrischen
drähten nicht fachgerecht montiert
weil sie die drähte volumen zu machen ob
zudem aufzeigen richtig kontakt da muss
mal über die direkte drähte viele user
group
zusammen 3d macht so richtig kontakt
für die betreiber der 26 hektar großen
finca ist es wichtig dass sie sich auf
ihre angestellten verlassen können
dass man erst einmal
mit dem thema
warum das denn jetzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hat es strom
hallo
[Musik]
hallo genau
wir nehmen so viel wir eingehen
das ist segment
eine autostunde vom park entfernt hatte
riemer müller eine schreinerei gefunden
die ihm buchstäblich die grundlage für
seine tiger trainings bietet
miriam aus der schweiz unterstützt ihn
ohne die freiwillige helfer wäre das
alles gar nicht ganz schön ist wirklich
das
dass man viele mythen und der extreme
spannbreite
von rückseiten das ist so cool da helfen
wir
[Musik]
täglich trainiert alexandra ihren
afrikanischen milch
[Musik]
gut
machst du mal starten
jawohl superman ist da gelandet
komm zu mir
[Musik]
super jetzt
genießt die aufmerksamkeit einfach mit
dabei sein zu können und wenn sich ein
vogel erst mal daran gewöhnt hat dann
braucht er das auch
ein bisschen zu gucken gehen
bewusst noch hierüber
immer weiter immer weiter immer weiter
immer war darüber sehr muss erst ab
sagte helfer karren für remo das
sägemehl in die arena
hast du gut gemacht
und alexander rist gesehen was sie mit
ihrem auto angesteckt
[Gelächter]
vier kubikmeter sägemehl die arena soll
die attraktion im park werden hier will
renault seine tiger vor publikum
trainieren
darf mal einen blick reinwerfen ich habe
mehrere grad
hoch geschickt auf dem podest sie allein
auf die mittlere stufe geflogen auf
dieses gelände wieder zurückkommen und
so gut gemacht
[Musik]
ich genieße das richtig kann einfach rum
stehen ein bisschen x pulse runterfahren
das tut mir ganz gut und macht mich
einfach glücklich
[Musik]
ist auch den mut zu
heute startet markus seine cowboy
karriere die chips die über hose aus
leder schützt vor dreck und gibt halt
auf dem sattel lässt das gehört nach
hinten
cowboy auf einer rinderfarm mit über
1000 tiere
markus lebt seinen bubentraum
[Musik]
[Applaus]
200 kälber werden markus und seine
kollegen heute impfen und brandmarken
das branding wie es im fachjargon heißt
ist ein kleines volksfest
familien nachbarn freunde alle treffen
sich auf dem feld
was machst du heute
nein ich fange die kälber ein und halte
sie fest ja festhalten
[Musik]
technik
so haben josephine und elena ihren papa
noch nie gesehen
[Musik]
markus kerber einfach vielleicht
nächstes jahr
über dem offenen feuer erhitzen die
cowboys die brandeisen
downloaded farmbesitzer persönlich
markiert die jungtiere mit der eisen
marke
[Applaus]
[Musik]
andere
machen
ungefähr 200
[Musik]
ja chef cabrio ist zufrieden mit markus
den schweizern macht ihr es nicht
schlecht
wir sind froh ihn zurück zu haben er mag
das wildwest leben
verpasste das sehen darauf hatte er sich
schon vor zwei jahren so gefreut jetzt
wird er zur ernte und hoffentlich noch
für viele jahre da sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seit einer woche erlebt merian nun auf
der pferde finca es waren hektische tage
os und miriam hatten kaum einmal zeit
füreinander
jetzt wollen sie einen blick auf die
neue heimat werfen
für die westschweizerin waren die ersten
tage nicht einfach besonders die ruppige
art von robert bereitet ihr
motto
team zurück
das mache ich ja ok verfahren
eine anreise mit bus aus lacht ja ich
glaube dass mir das in gefahr
mit so einem mist einfach thema wir
müssen immer zu machen wir werden
möglichst ganz sicher nicht ohne
aber ein richtiger sommer im himmel mit
dem wirklich beste gezählt gezählt im
jahr
es ist für mich die beste
[Musik]
remos großkatzen sind eigentlich kleine
angsthase nur langsam fassen sie
vertrauen in ihre neue heimat
doch nun da die arena fertig gebaut ist
ist es zeit einen weiteren schritt zu
wagen
also jetzt
probiere zum dessert schnitzler in
schwierigkeit ich glaube nicht dass in
köln sondern dass irgendwann wieder mal
direkt durch uhse könnte gegen einen
schnitt machen
was passiert
das
jetzt fertig langweilig
[Musik]
fuhsetal die kann ich ja genug
das ist interessanter als
die bahn
es kühlt sie sind froh jetzt
endlich gold zwitter die was lieber
moment länger als ist in so wie
eigentlich immer irgendwo etwas noch nie
existiert und dann ist nicht gut wird
eine
panik über und das ist ja dass das
eigentliche punkt sieht eine wo absolut
richtig und deutlich immer lässig und da
gibt es immer deutlich und vor dem herrn
das ist eigentlich ganz gut so
ich möchte erst
jetzt habe schnell gemerkt dass da
irgendwas läuft
weik macht rani
khedira
nachdem es zu beginn bald wie remo mit
den tigern zusammen in der arena
trainieren ein solches training soll das
highlight bei der park eröffnung sein
muss endlich entscheiden wir wenn jetzt
vorstelle ist also wenn ich sehe sich
nicht wohl und
sie sind ja um 60
das sieht die anklägerin
machen mit einer brille
das ist schon cool netze im eigenen im
eigenen park das macht spaß dass man
weiß
dass er nie konstruiert und
sie meditieren und
das ist
alles fein
und für die hauptrolle in der stecke
[Musik]
nach dem branding ist alexander mit den
kindern unterwegs auf dem riesigen
farmgelände
ihnen ist ein unterernährtes kälbchen
zur aufzucht angeboten worden
[Musik]
ein cowboy kollege bringt das kälbchen
zurück stuhls nach hause das tier ist
gut zwei wochen alt
[Musik]
die
hier mag doch gerne
und ein schluck
[Musik]
so erfreulich das glück bringt wird im
haus installiert die 90 sie uns genommen
nun erlebt
mit nunmehr
achten dass keine wirkung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auf der pferde finca hat sich eine
züchterin angemeldet sie interessiert
sich für studie luna
obwohl robert nicht gestütschef ist
hilft der erfahrene pferdeflüsterer
miriam beim herausputzen von studio luna
die zuchtstute ist wieder zu gerichten
noch an menschen gewöhnt es braucht viel
geduld und einfühlungsvermögen
um die stolze andalusien für die
präsentation bereit zu machen
fairer handel
zum ersten mal muss muss sein verkaufs
geschick unter beweis stellen
das geht so schnell schon interessenten
betroffen sind aber wirklich das große
modell
derzeit die fortsetzung der guten namen
hat das los einer entlassung hieß
betroffen sind riet beträgt richtig
aufbauen gezuckt haben parallel geht ist
das wunderschön
du hast doch ehrlich es die home-taste
rote zum hätte die vanessa borgmann ist
der nächste viel zu stellen das gute
ist ich weiß
und in der nächsten folge von auf und
davon präsentiert usd studie luna
die potenzielle käuferin hat klare
preisvorstellungen
merian für zum ersten mal eine
reitgruppe an und verschafft sich robert
respekt
im tierpark bekommt remo unerwarteten
besuch von den eltern sie werden gleich
eingespannt denn bald ist eröffnung und
die ist gefährdet
es toben heftige stürme
jetzt kurz vor
mensch
in kanada kümmert sich alexandra und das
geschwächte kalb und markus will eine
ausgewachsene kuh kaufen
2800 das ist viel geld
[Musik]
sie binden möchte
beckmann
[Musik]
huf und infos präsentiert wurde der
leyen für oliver längert oder weniger
lang weg sind